hey everybody it's Mike from order flows
and yeah today I want to go through a
couple of uh actually about four
questions that I got on a video that I
posted the other day about you know one
of the the trade setups that I like to
take it's the uh it's basically the
exhaustion print at the high and this
was the chart from uh what day was this
the 13th right I was talking about this
uh one lot that traded up here at the
high of the day you know on the retest
uh going into the high today which is
your resistance and the Market's selling
off from it okay and there were some
interesting
um conversations in the comments section
so I just want to go over some of them
because you know they're very relevant
and I want to clarify some things just
so
um you know you guys could get a better
understanding of what I'm
you know trying to tell you so you don't
get it confused with uh some stuff so
let me uh just go through the couple of
the questions first the sort of the the
simpler ones um you know Michael I like
your name um
or a couple questions do I prefer
trading bonds over e-minis and NQ says
he's trying to transition from es to
bonds as they seem a bit more
predictable yeah I prefer them I prefer
interest rates definitely over the
equities
you know I find the moves uh truer and
you don't get the sort of this
excess volatility that you see in
um the equities right the equities
have can have very big movements that
you just don't necessarily see in the
bonds you know it's a different type of
Market you know equities are cash
settled the type of participants is
completely different whereas you know
the bond market isn't
um you know involving a lot of retail
Traders you know I don't want to say hot
money but you know I just find the moves
you know a bit truer in the order flow
and
you know just for me personally it's a
bit easier to read because it's
very strong liquidity it's easy to get
in and out of you know when equities are
moving very fast the order book really
thins out but at least in you know the
interest rates you do have size there so
you know you're not giving up extra
ticks trying to get in and out of a
position
so you know if you're trying to make the
switch from you know equities into
interest rates a great contract to take
a look at you know to start to sort of
get your feet wet
is the the five years right the ZF now
you know there are micro contracts on
the interest rates but you know those
things barely trade you know it it's
it's not uh it's not worth the effort to
look at them you know the five years is
a great contract I think I got a
five-year chart here I could just pull
up really quick this is my um
tenure uh ZF is the symbol on the fives
and again you know there's nice volume
now it the difference between the five
years and you know the bonds is
five years trades in quarter ticks right
one full tick so from 108 29 to 108.30
is actually Four ticks in the bonds it
would just move from 29 to 30. and
the that makes each tick worth like uh
seven dollars and 81 cents so like the
full tick would be 31.25 you know you
divide that by four if you had 781
7.81 per tick and again you know if
you're thinking about making that move
over it's a good contract to sort of get
used to trading that market because
again you know bonds
generally move slower than the equity
markets you know but you know there are
times where you know we're very interest
rate sensitive market right now where
you know is you know everyone's always
talking what's the FED gonna do what's
the fact going to do what's the fact
going to do
um you know with inflation at these
levels so there there is some extra
volatility at times you know like around
a Fed meeting obviously or around an
important number and if non-farm
payrolls uh CPI obviously you know I
kind of missed the days when CPI was
just another number that would come out
but um you know sort of to answer your
question
why I prefer trading bonds over es is
you know I just find the order flow a
bit easier to read for me right and
that's due to you know sort of this x I
don't say excess volatility but the more
volatility that you see in the equity
markets than you see in
um the interest rate markets generally
um but he also uh Michael also asks
another question why would you wait for
the candle to close do candle or their
time frame actually matter when they
close well you know it's a reference
point okay because you know when you're
trading a
time-based chart okay time-based charts
obviously different than a volume based
chart tick based chart arrange based
chart right range base charts
you know are formed when price is moving
right so
obviously from the open to close we're
generally going higher now on a
time-based chart time you know
a five minute chart after five minutes
boom it just automatically starts a new
bar and the the thing that I keep in
mind right with time-based charts is you
know sometimes the chart just ends you
know right at at the minute marker or
whatever you know time period you're
looking at but my reference is from the
open of that bar just as you would look
at you know you look at the market
here you turn on CNBC oh Dao is down
fine you know
50 points today okay what's the
references from well it's from the the
days you know the previous days close
which you know generally is the open but
you got to have a reference that you're
measuring it from right where are you
determining you know is this Market
going higher or is it going lower right
now if you're trading a let's get back
to the Chart here okay so this is you
know a five minute chart okay so I know
that this big green candle here yeah you
know the momentum is going higher right
Market is going up obviously it's a
green candle I mean we you know green
means Market's going up but from you
know where it opened I know that where
we are moving higher right so you gotta
have some sort of reference that's why I
wait for the bars to close because you
know if you watch a bar there's times
where
the market you know looks bullish very
early on
but then things change especially if
you're on a longer time frame you know
your 15 minute chart 30 minute chart you
know things could look bullish the first
five minutes and you're thinking oh I
got you know it's going up I gotta get
long you get long but the whole bar
hasn't played out right and then you
know
three minutes before the bar closes a
very bearish information comes out and
the bar closes down and it's a red bar
nearly thinking why'd I take that trade
so yes I for me you know
candle closes bar closes are important
right there's a reason why
um you know a high and a low is made
over that time period
and again you know I like to reference
where the market closed relative to
where it opens because generally a bar
is going to open at the same price the
previous bar closed more or less you
know maybe it might be a tick above or a
tick below depending on where the bid
offer was when the market closed and if
the market was moving but generally it's
going to be you know right around the
same level the the open of the current
bar is going to be right around the same
price as the close
of the previous bar so yeah for me in my
analysis yes they matter right and I
know in my trading I've tried that you
know I've tried to get long as soon as
something bullish comes in the order
flow but you know that
it could just be a big order hitting the
market and you know I'm getting excited
over one order hitting the market I want
to see you know continual buy orders
coming in
to sort of support my thesis if you will
on why I'm getting long because just
because I think you know I should get
long if nobody else in the world thinks
you know this Market's going up it's not
going to go up even if I you know I
could think all I want and then hope and
pray but that's not what's going to get
the market to go up it's the other
buyers I also want to see you know the
the continued buying going up okay so I
hope that answers your question
and
again there was there was there was a
nice little heated debate nice little
thread going
um on this chart here let me just pull
it up this was the the five year chart
uh where are we ZN
okay because I was talking about this
single print here this one lot okay so
the market you know it had shot up on
the the number it made a new high by a
tick sort of came
off a little bit came back up traded one
contract up here I said that's the last
buyer that's buying and then the market
sold off okay so
um you have no had you know he started
an interesting thread and you know
there's a lot of people jumped in
um to to sort of explain it out but you
know I I want to rather than me type it
out you know I'd rather explain it out
um because he says you know at uh first
you know
um he was talking about this bar at 8
10. he retested the 755 High okay then
it went higher
so let's take a look that at that bar
here so this was the 755 bar at it
tested it here at 8 10 and then went
higher it didn't sell off I mean you
have no sort of asking why did this one
go higher
as opposed to this one selling off well
again that sort of goes back to that
previous question on waiting for the bar
to close right why I wait for the bar to
close
this bar is still showing you know even
though it's it's you know kind of a
small bullish candle it's still bullish
okay for one right it's still closing
green so I know the momentum is still to
the upside so there still could be some
buying this bar here closed down right
we're closing on on our low even though
this one is off of the high it's still
the momentum is still to the upside so
there's still some bind now had this
next bar this bar at 8 15 started
trading lower you know honestly I
wouldn't take it I don't like taking
bearish signals off green candles right
if I'm looking for a bearish signal it's
going to be off of a red candle
um
so you know that's the reason right and
it goes back to sort of the earlier
question from Michael why is you know
the bar closed for me important because
it's still telling me you know sort of
the momentum that's in the market the
market is still going up right green
candle green candle you know two green
candles I'm not ready to fade it yet
um yeah I want to see the price action
right everyone talks about price action
price action
is still going higher okay even though
it just traded one contract up there it
did come off okay fine but it's not
coming off enough for me to be bearish
right it's still holding above you know
the the open or you know the close of
the previous bar so it's still
technically in an uptrend if it were to
close down then yeah I would have
kind of the same thought that I have up
here now this obviously is a resistance
area right it's your high of the day
right people say well how do you know
that's reason what's the high of the day
you've already made that high there were
sellers we hit up up there and the
market came off right that's what
happens at resistance markets sell off
from resistance now we're testing it and
we don't go higher
um you know this
is not necessarily a resistance area I
mean it is a I guess you could call it a
swing high if that but that's even a
stretch because we're still inside of
this that big bar from you know when the
number came out right in here at 7 30
and we even poke higher so it's still
you know inside of the range that you've
been trading so I I I think calling it a
swing high would be a bit of a stretch
but again
what's going on in the price action of
the candle well it's still bullish right
it's still got that bullish move in it
right it's still a green candle
so
um you know I hope that answers that
first part because that sort of goes
into the second part
um that y'all going to get into actually
this first question I answered came in
first before this one it says that 8 28
25 8 30
there were no sellers at the bottom it
showed zero yet the market went down all
right so let's take a look back at the
chart here so
um
what was it here here 8 28 25 8 30 okay
and the market went down this is
different because
this you have
these are already red candles right if
I'm looking for Price exhaustion I'm not
looking for exhaustion at the bottom of
a red candle Market's already moving
down I'm looking at the top of the red
candle that's where you're going to find
the exhaustion right because a move
going up is going to get exhausted
eventually right the people are going to
lose interest in buying they're going to
have no more money left to buy with okay
now when it's going down this actually
the zero this is what normal order flow
looks like now in order flow analysis
there's there's a term I didn't invent
this term this term was invented by
others you know in the early 2000s
called unfinished auction this is what a
finished auction looks like now we don't
have to draw a zero on there but
what it would look like nor what it
really should look like is just at seven
and a half there's 24 against this 289
so seven and a half eight is what the
market was when the bar closed okay down
here this is a unfinished auction at uh
two and a half
and there was no volume here at uh at O2
so it was actually
at this bar at the bottom of this bar
was actually two bid at two and a half
the reason why there's no zero printed
down there is because
you would have to for the zero to print
you'd have to go a little bit lower on
the offer side there's a zero here
because this Market was trading
um seven and a half at eight right I
hope you can understand that this is the
bottom of the bar the bottom of the bar
right there's no volume that traded
below here just as there's no volume
that traded below here if this was what
is called a finished auction
there would be a zero here okay now
there's a whole way to trade unfinished
auctions or as some people refer to them
as unfinished business right when you
have unfinished business often Traders
are looking for the market to come back
and make a finished auction where there
is that zero at the bottom of the bar
okay or you know the top of a bar like
here right the 642 and the 850 this is
an unfinished auction up here
so even though there's the zero there
it's essentially it's there because the
software is telling it to put a field in
there right put a value rather not a
field put a value in that field it could
easily just be 24 against 29 with
nothing here okay so just because you
see that zero on the bottom of the offer
side in a red candle
that isn't a sign of exhaustion right
for red candles you're looking for
exhaustion at the top of the bars just
as on green candles you're looking for
exhaustion on the bottom of bars
so I hope that clears that up a bit um
you know it's just one of those things
where at the tops of green candles all
right generally you're going to have the
zero on the bid offer side at the top
right because this Market went up and it
was seven and a half at eight
okay and there's no volume here if there
was one contract traded at eight then
you'd see a one here
right then that means that it was eight
it actually was eight bid this Market
never went eight bid that's why there's
a zero here
okay just as here in here and here it
never went offered at seven and a half
it never went offered at seven it never
went offered at six and a half in this
bar obviously the next bars we did but
in this bar it never went offered at
seven and everyone offered at six and a
half that's why there's
a zero there okay and there's there's no
volume in there like obviously zero is
just means no volume so
that's not necessarily a sign that you
know the market should go lower right
because the Market's already moving
lower but it just hasn't gone offered
there yet
okay so I I hope that clears that up for
you
um yeah I know you mean I do appreciate
your questions
um you know and and your comments you
know there was a comment from
um Sandstorm feline you know I
appreciate the amount of information you
put out it's a nice change of pace to
see including crypto markets
yeah you know um crypto markets are
are interesting in terms of order flow
because it's a bit different than say
um you know Futures because you know
with Futures you know there's a fixed
contract size whereas crypto you can
trade pretty much any amount you know
five you could buy five dollars worth of
bitcoin I mean you can't buy buy five
dollars worth of uh e-mini contract
um you know you gotta put down margin
and all that but you know with crypto
you could buy pretty much any any amount
and
you know at first it made it a little
bit difficult to till we sort of figured
out you know how to
price it in Satoshi so it'll show up on
the chart right and you know sort of
aggregate the
aggregate the volume and and sort of
work our way around it but it does you
know there are things in crypto markets
that
you can use order flow with to look at
and to be honest
um I do watch
crypto and I don't trade crypto at all
for me it's not you know when you think
a term
trading crypto really you know there's
not a lot of people that are
active in the way they're active and say
futures or stocks you know a lot of in
and out in and out you know day trading
um but you can watch crypto on a
15-minute chart a 30 minute chart
um you know for sort of you know longer
term views or you know the whole Buy and
Hold for a few days
um it's nice to see how how it reacts
That Swing highs and swing lows or if
you see you know big supportive volume
coming in or resistance coming in you
know with with heavy volume on the offer
or if a market is breaking there are
there are nice things yeah I'll I'll try
to get some more crypto videos up
um you know again the thing is I use
ninjatrader they do have if you get you
could download ninjatrader they connect
to the coinbase uh data feed actually
then it's free of charge
um I do know that you know there are
other softwares out there I think Excel
charts was one that has a footprint and
um but you know that that's a paid one
um and then there's a few other
Footprints out there but I
used to watch eth but not anymore I
focused mainly on
Bitcoin I do I do watch Doge people
probably laugh at me for saying that but
you know it it's actually a nice
contract in terms of how it moves with
the order flow
so yeah I'll try and get some more
videos on uh on crypto up
um it's a fast yeah it's just it's just
it's a vehicle for trading right and you
know whether it's crypto or e-mini S PS
or Tesla stock
um you know I'm always fascinated on
seeing how
what parts of order flow matter more in
different markets so thanks everyone you
know be sure to like And subscribe the
channel and you know keep those comments
coming I I won't necessarily make a
video on all of them but you know the
ones that I think are interesting and
are relevant uh most definitely try to
because it's uh the thing with order
flow is you know it's information and
you know you really behooves you to to
use it okay so again thanks everyone and
I'll catch you guys on the next video
bye-bye